STEVE BAZYL: Hi everyone, and
thank you for joining us for
another Google Drive GDL.
Today, we are going to talk
about one of the apps in the
Chrome Web Store for Drive.
This is a Draw.io.
It's a nice collaborative
drawing map
using Google Drive.
And today to talk about this and
give us a demo and talk a
little bit of how it was
implemented, we have a special
guest with us today, which is
David Benson from Draw.io.
Want to say hi, David?
DAVID BENSON: Hi there.
STEVE BAZYL: So I want to
thank you for joining us
today, taking time.
I know it's pretty late for
you over in the UK.
But thank you very much for the
time, and thank you for
building Draw.io.
There's some things about the
app that I think are going to
be really interesting for this
audience, particularly that
it's an open source app, and
people can use it as a great
learning example.
But I was hoping that you could
start us off with just
an overview of the app and maybe
show us a demo of the
Drive integration and some of
the features that you think
are kind of the cooler parts.
DAVID BENSON: Sure.
OK.
Is my screen live?
STEVE BAZYL: Yes, it is.
DAVID BENSON: Cool.
So this is Draw.io.
The really easy way to introduce
it is it looks a bit
like Visio, another web app.
The sort of diagrams you can
draw, things like flow charts,
UML diagrams, networking
diagrams, electrical diagrams.
There's lots of different
types of org
charts, and so on.
So it's probably quite familiar
to somebody who's
uses OmniGraffle or Visio.
They're various online tools
as well like [INAUDIBLE]
charts, and so on, [INAUDIBLE]
thing.
The difference between us and
some of the more commercial
tools is that this isn't
a commercial venture.
There's a very public source
to the whole product.
Commercially what we do is we
sell the underlying library.
This is very much more
of a technology
demonstration library.
Now, up here you can see what
I'm doing is a bit of
jgraph.com.
And what that means is I'm
integrated with Drive.
When users first come to the
site they'll see a button here
which is integrated
with Google Drive.
And prior to having the Drive
integration, when you did Save
As, all we did is echo to
the local file system.
When you did Load, we'd open
from the local file system.
We [INAUDIBLE] then to things
like Google App Engine and
particularly Drive.
It gave us the chance to build
a useful application.
Whereas before, to be honest,
we didn't really have the
resources to take a library and
a basic example to do the
user management, the storage
management, the scalability.
We still have to tap
the resources.
So when you log in with Drive,
you're not actually going to
see that because the pop-up is
come up and ask you which
account I want to log in as.
We'll actually come back
to that pop-up.
It's one of the issues
that we haven't--
now when I say Save, after I
save this drawing one, for
example, that will actually
go into my--
let me switch my drawings
over to here.
And that is the drawing one.
I can save it as something a
bit more meaningful if you
want just to prove that
we are online.
STEVE BAZYL: I believe you.
DAVID BENSON: And then those
people familiar with Drive
know that there are restrictions
you have, for
example, if you integrate with
the Chrome Web Store.
No, it's not the Chrome Web
Store, it's the Drive SDK that
enables you to open directly
from Drive back into the
application.
So what we originally
did with Draw.io--
it used to be called Diagram,
if anyone is confused--
is when Drive first came back
out in April, we took the edit
example, and we integrated
that in with our backend.
Now, that worked fine.
There are various nuances
with Drive integration.
And a lot of these are listed on
the best practices page on
the Drive docs.
And they're worth taking notice
of because we missed
out things like multiple account
management, taking
account of where users wanted
to open their files, which
folder for example.
And the users came straight
back because they really
expected these to be in because,
of course, with a
local operating system, when
you open something, create
something in a folder, you
expect it to be created in
that folder rather than
in the [? root. ?]
So we made a few improvements
to the Java backend.
And we had a discussion,
actually, on Stack Overflow
because we were really
interested in a JavaScript
client rather than having to
go through our server.
And fairly rapidly a working
JavaScript client came out.
And as soon as we could, we
tried to integrate it.
We found it very interesting,
the whole idea of going
directly from the JS
client to Drive.
There's a number of advantages
both for us as developers and
both the users.
I mean, things like privacy,
for example.
Now our data doesn't
go [INAUDIBLE]
tool because before with the
Java version, everything was
going via our servers
and proxy.
And this makes privacy
much simpler.
It makes security
We never see the user's data.
We can't loose the
user's data.
It's much simpler in that we
don't even have to have
sessions enabled
on our backend.
And compared to the Java
applications, it's a hell of a
lot better [INAUDIBLE]
that we have to upload every
time we upload the app.
So we made the decision a few
weeks back to actually go to
deployment with the JavaScript
version.
It looks pretty much exactly the
same as the Java version,
because, of course, all that's
changed is the Drive
integration.
That's the point at which
we switched over
to the Draw.io domain.
Previously, we were diagram.ly,
mainly because .io
suffix is a lot cooler
than .ly.
Now, in terms of the
authorization, when you use a
server you've got to think
of server flow.
And when you use a JS client,
you've got client flow.
One tip for anyone who wants
to switch over, I would
suggest is if you have the
server flow in place, leave
the server functionality in
place in case the user's in
the middle of editing.
Because if they're in the middle
of editing and they see
all the backend functionality
exactly as it was before, they
can carry on editing.
And if the JavaScript client
doesn't update, they can still
come to the site after you've
deployed and it
will work as before.
So we actually managed to hot
deploy the app using the
JavaScript client library
without having to force a
refresh or without having
to have maintenance.
So, I mean, that was kind
of coincidental.
We didn't plan it that way.
But if you are planning to
switch over from server flow
to client flow, it is better to
do it all in one go rather
than, for example, [INAUDIBLE]
keep the authorization on the
server, because you do get
that advantage.
One downside of doing it is--
it's all very well that the
user gets privacy and
security and so on.
And one thing we didn't realize
until after the event,
is, of course, we lost
a lot of logging.
When there was a problem
on the server--
most server side implementations
have some
degree of logging.
Of course, when there's an
authorization failure, the
user would email in saying
that they have a problem
authorizing, we realized
that we had no
logs to look at anymore.
So it's worth considering
there are various
implementations for fairly
simply sending logging data up
to the server and storing it.
You've got to be aware of
privacy again with that.
If you're claiming that you're
ultra private with their data,
and yet you're shifting stuff up
to the server, you have to
be really careful.
On a slightly related note as
well, in terms of the scopes
for Drive, users are really
quite savvy about the level of
permissions that you ask for.
I don't know if I can
show you here.
I think I'll have to
uninstall the app.
But, I mean, when it asks to
install your app, it will say
do you want me to be able to
open and save files from all
of your Drive or just
the application?
Do you want to be able to do
this when the user is offline,
and so on and so forth.
When you switch from server to
client, the scope that causes
the permission that when you
want to be able to edit your
stuff when you're offline, that
disappears, because, of
course, if you're client only,
you have to be online to make
those changes.
I think there's a slight
misunderstanding about that
permission.
I don't think that's saying that
they're waiting for you
to go away and do something
really weird with your data.
But users just--
I think there's a comment
somewhere in the Drive docs,
the less permissions
it asks for, the
more people will install.
And that's definitely
our experience.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, those
are great bits of tips.
One thing before you continue,
where can developers find the
source for this?
DAVID BENSON: They you can find
the source on GitHub.
It's under organization,
JGraph.
It's github.com/jgraph,
and then you see all
our projects, Draw.io.
There's lots of Draw.io.
mxGraph is the underlying
diagram library, and it's a
combination of the two that
actually makes what you see.
We do have some build scripts
too to use in closure to put
all the JavaScript together
just to make
them load a bit faster.
There are instructions.
There's actually quite a long
video on our G+ stream
on how to do it.
It's about a 25-minute video,
which explains the chronology
how to [INAUDIBLE].
And on this subject, actually,
on GitHub there's a piece of
functionality that enables you
to statically deploy what you
have in your master branch.
I think it's gh-pages.
This is the gh-pages deployed
as a static app.
Now, of course, it is
the app itself.
And because it's using the JS
library [INAUDIBLE], I can log
in because their server's
require to use the JS.
And I will be able to then
save that back to my--
[INAUDIBLE]
call this GitHub.
And that will appear,
I really hope.
So that's an example using
a completely static site.
There's no server, nothing
behind it.
And actually I've got
a really geeky idea.
I'll suggest that later on.
STEVE BAZYL: I was going to
say, you could even try
hosting this within Drive
itself, with [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID BENSON: Well,
I have done that.
So what I did is I put all
the code onto Drive.
I made default to public.
And you start getting into kind
of metric situations.
So we have this feature
where you can
say move from templates.
And, OK, I haven't
got the password.
But a bunch of templates come
out and they're based on
actual XML of our diagrams.
So what I could do is load
the diagram from my Drive
instance, change it, and then
the templates that appear into
the static deployment,
they're changed.
And, of course, what I'd love
for someone to do is to create
a source control app using the
JS client that's built into
every deployment with the
data it comes with.
I mean, that would be great.
I'd pay money to see that.
STEVE BAZYL: That would actually
be pretty cool.
So in the sources is there
anything in particular a
developer should be looking at,
in particular related to
Drive and authentication?
DAVID BENSON: Sure.
In the unhelpfully known
war/js/diagramly, there is a
helpfully known file called
GoogleDrive.js.
Probably could do with
a few more comments.
I will give you warning,
it's the [? v1 ?].
It does the job.
It works as intended.
I think for first refractory--
if anyone's wondering, it's
Apache license.
We'll put an Apache license
at the top.
I think for the first
refractory, what we're going
to do is have a more formal
state machine, because a lot
of the errors that come back,
you have to think very
carefully about what you're
going to do and what state
you're in when they come back,
and so on and so forth.
When you add multiple account
management into the mix, it
becomes really, really
quite complex.
And you have to consider, for
example, if you've got a 401
authorized, it might be, one,
that your session has expired.
It might be, two, that you've
logged out, back
in as another user.
So if you're assuming that your
session has expired, if
you try to be clever and try
to log back in, and you've
actually gone as a different
user, you've got it wrong.
So what we're going to do is
follow a bit more of the state
design pattern, finite station,
whatever people call it.
And we're going to draw
a pretty diagram
using Draw.io, of course.
But we need to implement
[? curly ?] arrows.
[INAUDIBLE]
for that.
And we're going to formalize
it a bit more
so it's a bit clearer.
And then if people have got
problems, if developers--
because any developer is welcome
to take the code and
use it if it's useful.
We may even put it on to a
separate GitHub project,
because I doubt people
particularly want to take the
whole thing in order
to use it.
So we'll probably have a
refractory and say there will
be explicit [INAUDIBLE]
states.
We'll give them names.
We'll draw out where
the transitions go.
I think that will help people
to deploy themselves.
And it will help them to report
bugs to us more clearly.
And help get it right in our
head to be able to sort out
the few cases where
we have problems.
I mean, in terms of where we
do have problems, as I
mentioned, you can't actually
see when I sign out and back
in again, I get a
little pop-up.
One known issue is the fact
you have to click on the
pop-up twice in order to
get it to authenticate.
I believe that's being
looked at.
Another issue is because of
client side, when the token
expires, when the authorization
token expires--
that happens after
about an hour.
So let's say you do a save and
your token has expired, you
will get a 401.
It's unauthorized.
Now, when you get the response
back, you're no longer in the
user event because you're
in the call back of the
authorization.
Because you're not in the call
back of the authorization, if
you try and authorize, it will
fire a pop-up and that will be
blocked if, like most browsers,
you block pop-ups.
So a similar case, actually,
with the file picker--
so I think this is written
about in the Drive
documentation.
And it's well worth doing
because like everyone, we're
far too lazy to do
that on our own.
And what we do is when we hit
the file, we pop another
really bad dialogue and
we say how do you want
to open this file.
Open and the diagram opens,
[INAUDIBLE] drawing.
And the reason we're doing this
is because we want the
event that's fired when we click
OK to be able to open
that in a new tab.
Because if you take it straight
from the call back of
the picker, it will fire a
pop-up that will be blocked.
Now, we scratched our heads.
Is it better to have a pop-up
that's blocked and try to tell
people to allow it or not?
We're not really sure.
We're not really user
experience experts.
And we generally post on our
G+ desperately trying to
persuade people to tell us
their thoughts on that.
I mean, this is a bit
of a first run.
So I think we are going to
polish various things.
For example, when the session
expires and you would attempt
to save, and then you have
this problem that
authorization can't happen,
it will go to pop-up.
Of course, what we thought about
after that is when we
get the token, we know the
duration for which
the token is valid.
So what we could do is set off
a timer and then say after
that timer is expired, if
somebody clicks save, do an
authorization first because
we know it's expired.
Then we'll have the
authorization to save a work
and we won't have some silly
dialogue to avoid the pop-up.
STEVE BAZYL: One thing you can
try is-- and I haven't looked
at all the source to see if
you're already doing this.
But the JavaScript
client has--
one of the options you can
include is what they call
immediate mode, which is very
useful for cases where you're
expecting the user to have
previously authorized.
And rather than use a pop-up
it will use, basically, a
hidden iframe with
[? cross ray ?]
messaging to check to see if the
user is authorized, and if
so, update the token.
And that should work OK even
if you're not within a user
initiated event.
DAVID BENSON: OK.
I think we might have
looked at that.
But I think there were problems
with the multiple
account management.
STEVE BAZYL: There may be.
I think I've seen your Stack
Overflow thread about some
issues with hinting at the user
ID for which one to use.
And, yeah, something we'll
look at for sure.
DAVID BENSON: I mean, is it
usable in production is
something you might ask.
I think it pretty much is
because we probably need to
spend a couple more weeks.
We could iron out some
of the issues.
And a lot of our users are
feeding back to us about
various issues.
So I think with a bit of
ingenuity the sort of last 10%
of issues could be polished
out to the point that you
don't particularly notice.
I mean, one slight issue is, as
far as we can tell, in the
Internet Explorer line, the
library uses XDR, and that
requires the protocol to be
identical on the end point as
whatever it is that sends
it, i.e., SSL.
So we couldn't get that to
work outside of SSL.
So on HTTP you can get
everything to work except IE9.
So we have to put an
SSL certificate on
it to have IE9 working.
And apologies to our
Firefox users.
We put the wrong certificate on
and you get a big warning
on a pop-up.
But we are going to fix
that, obviously.
STEVE BAZYL: David, when you're
not showing the app, if
you want to talk directly to
viewers, it'd be cool if you
stopped sharing your
screen so we can--
DAVID BENSON: Oh, yep.
[INAUDIBLE].
STEVE BAZYL: That's it.
So this has all been really
great information.
So do you have any wish list for
things that you'd like to
see from Drive or from our SDK
or just Google in general to
make this better?
We already know about some
issues around multi-log on
with the JS client.
But I'm curious what your
impressions are
of the Drive SDK.
What can we be doing better to
help developers like yourself?
DAVID BENSON: For us to have
actually gone into deployment
with it, we're pretty
happy with it.
There's minor nuances like the
double click on the pop-up for
multiple accounts, but other
than that, I don't think
anything else is
insurmountable.
Multiple accounts does make it a
lot more complex, as I said.
But that's kind of
unavoidable.
And anyone thinking about
avoiding multiple accounts, I
wouldn't because a lot of users
now have the business
Google account and
they're private.
And there's not but about five
business apps on business
accounts and the private one.
And users came back very quickly
complaining about lack
of multiple accounts.
So there's nothing
particularly I
would complain about.
In fact, I was very, very
happy when the JS client
library came out because I've
never really liked,
architecturally, this idea
of always having to
proxy via the server.
I think the idea of going via
the client is much better,
whether or not users understand
the advantages of
privacy and security,
probably most don't.
But, I mean, it also
gives a lot of good
possibilities for flow mode.
And one thing we're going
to do is have a look at
application cache and
the local storage.
Because the thing with Drive is
I've noticed that Drive has
a better run time than most
cloud computing platforms,
because it's probably
a lot simpler.
Because the more simple it
is, generally the longer
it stands up to--
STEVE BAZYL: I'm not sure
I would say simple.
But we appreciate
the compliment.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah, yeah.
It looks simple.
Well, I mean, the server we
have, for example-- the thing
is with the server is quite
often it's a user error which
brings the server down.
We've had more outages because
we have deployed something
corrupted or whatever, rather
than the actual
server going down.
Now, if you're deploying fairly
much static content,
and you're using the
application cache--
so even if our server goes
offline, somebody could come
on with the application cache.
They could read and
write to Drive.
It's much better continuity
for the user.
That combined with say local
storage, if you went out of
range on the device.
And we do work on tablets
as well with Draw.io.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, I was
actually just going to ask
about mobile and whether or
not you've looked into a
mobile version that's either
optimized HTML5 or native.
DAVID BENSON: What we did is
we changed a few of the
handlers we call them.
We made them a lot bigger.
We moved them around.
It's not a massive change.
It looks quite similar.
It could probably do with
a bit of a change.
I mean, if you look at
it on a four-inch
phone, it's pretty unusable.
But I'm not sure how you could
really make that usable
without a huge change.
But we don't actually
use Canvas.
A lot of people assume
we use Canvas.
We actually use SVG with VML
on the Internet Explorer,
because we started writing
an XGraph [INAUDIBLE]
back in 2005.
And I don't think Chrome was
around then and I think it was
Internet Explorer 6 and so on.
So it's not that we're really
retro, it's just when we
started it.
STEVE BAZYL: This has been
fantastic, and just great
information for developers.
I obviously encourage everyone
to check it out.
And I also just want
to thank you.
We just started our Google+
Community for Drive
Developers, and you've been
very active there already
providing some really useful
tips to other developers.
I really do appreciate that very
much, and along with the
time that you've taken today.
Before we wrap up, I don't know
if there's anything else
you wanted to share with
developers or tips, or if
there's anything that developers
should know about
working with Drive that you
could sum up quickly?
DAVID BENSON: I would say that
the JavaScript support for the
client library could
actually be more
important than Drive itself.
I mean, I've said I've felt for
a long time this is really
the way to go with web
applications, and I don't
really see any cloud storage
providers providing something
equivalent in terms of
simplicity and the advantages
to both users and developers.
I'm very interested to see
the way this goes.
And it's developing fast.
We considered supporting other
platforms, but as long as
Drive, particularly the JS
client, develops this fast, I
don't think we'll bother,
because I think this is
actually, technically, quite a
long way ahead of alternatives
at the moment.
STEVE BAZYL: Cool.
Well, thank you very much.
I think we will wrap up there.
Again, thank you very much for
your time and for building
Draw.io, and your willingness
to share that
with the broader community.
That's all for today, and I
don't know if we have our
topic for Thursday, but stay
tuned on Google Developers
Live or the Google+ Community
for Drive Developers, and
we'll keep everyone up
to date as to what
Thursday's topic will be.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]